what's up reject nation so here's the
deal with this video because you know
the way we're talking about this
wrecking like this news just broke but
actually you might have heard about this
already a week ago thought i lost the
footage apparently didn't lose the
footage so this video just gave to you a
weekly
[Music]
greg and john here today and whoa
i just learned this i just learned this
john doesn't know this yet
i told you on our camera surprise video
to me
we may know who's actually playing the
new joker in matt reeves the batman
franchise obviously we knew the joker
would eventually come around in this
franchise we don't know if he's gonna
appear in the batman the first
installment but obviously they already
have deals in place to do sequels if
they've got all these other villains in
there they're planning the joker to
appear in here sorry to everyone who has
been wanting arthur fleck to cross over
with robert pattinson that's not going
to be the case we never believed that
was going to be the case obviously take
this with a grain of salt i actually can
totally see this choice i can believe
this choice and i like this choice quite
a bit i think this choice is actually
great and it fits in well with the rest
of the cast and if you don't want this
to be spoiled in case it's true click
off now i believe it could be real are
you ready to learn this john i'm ready
as i'll ever be so this was leaked
scooped from des moines world they have
an instagram page a reddit and usually
they actually talk about celebrity
gossip but once in a while they do talk
about leaks they've been right a lot of
the time i'm gonna show you guys the
image on screen
right now
des moines posted i have really locked
down information that probably will send
the internet in a swirl and it's a
hundred percent true barry kogan will be
playing the joker on the new batman
you're welcome exclusive info and i was
like what olivia told me about this it
came up on a twitter feed of mine from
vengeance at bat source take this for a
grain of salt but des moines world has
had a pretty good track record
absolutely claims that barry kogan is
playing the joker lots of people believe
that he was secretly playing mad hatter
which would have been a good choice for
him too but this role is obviously much
bigger and to add just more validity to
this eric cogan who is the brother of
barry said so it's finally out my
brother playing the joker in the new
batman unreal stuff he has since deleted
this and we could all take a guess as to
why he deleted this although it still
might not be true taking everything with
a great assault why i think barry cogan
would be a great choice last time you
guys might have seen him was obviously
in the movie eternals where he got to
play druid he's done other movies as
well like killing of a sacred deer where
he got a lot of critical acclaim for
that role he's in a movie i really like
a lot of you like it quite a bit too
american animals he's just one of those
actors that inhabits darkness
you know what i mean you can see a frame
of him and you're like there's something
dark and mischievous about this
individual and he's just so excellent at
those roles the idea of seeing him
alongside colin farrell who he would be
reuniting with after killing of a sacred
deer the likes of colin farrell paul
dano he's just that that kind of actor
who fits in that category of ensemble
but john if this is true what do you
think i'm excited actually i mean it's
funny i was expecting either a meme or
some kind of very controversial pick and
that yeah i think he's got all the
spontaneity as an actor he can
definitely embody darkness and chaotic
energy for sure yeah he's not like the
first name i'd have thought of but for
his stature in hollywood right now for
what he's proven of his acting ability i
think it's a great choice to show us
yeah this guy's got chops but also now
he's gonna have an opportunity to really
go hog wild yeah with this role whatever
that means for him but you know given
given the type of actor he seems to be
i'm very excited to see that uh what
that turns into rather than like amused
but worried with like a jared leto type
you know sure and one thing that you
guys if you've been following the
channel for a while whenever we talk
about new jokers one thing i've always
wanted to see done with a new type of
joker is more similar to the betrayal
that you might have seen the animated
movie under the red hood not exactly
like a heath ledger or you know jack
nicholson where it's like high-pitched
nasally voice and super wild eccentric i
feel like barry cogan could do a little
bit more of that subdued joker but still
have a lot of that maniacal nature to
him the joker who's the quiet guy but
he's funny when it counts yeah i don't
know deranged when it counts i don't
know about like quiet but something that
might have maybe not as high pitched or
nasally of a voice but even a little bit
of a deeper voice i've always wanted to
see kind of that version of joker done
and when you look at kind of the way
they've been adapting the characters
just from the trailers alone like
usually when we think of you know edward
enigma but this time edward nash inside
of the as a role the riddler for paul
dano obviously that's very different
than what we're used to from seeing the
riddler usually very
eccentric with some borderline comedic
kind of kind of character you got paul
dano who has a much more subdued
performance here with the deeper voice i
don't want like barry cogan to jump in
here and do that
but dude villains universe but something
that fits along those lines but you know
you got colin farrell who is the penguin
in the in this franchise he feels more
like a comic book character in the
trailer more so than paul dano has been
coming across in the trailers and that's
kind of what i mean is having
that type of take inside of this matt
reeves world i just feel like when i
heard that i'm like wow barry coke that
that fits that just
fits for me it's not 100 confirmed
obviously right now we just chalk it up
to a rumor take it with a grain of salt
but they they've had they've gotten some
things right in the past and if it is
right i'm all on board for it oh yeah
that would be very cool if this is
actually real i mean you know you pulled
up this tweet here and i don't want to
read too much into other people's tweets
but they did pull the arkham asylum
image of the joker which is one of my
favorite joker portrayals that comic
serious house and serious earth so if
they could bring some of that
inspiration i mean you know matt reeves
universe seems very much in the dark i
mean batman comes with darkness but i
can feel especially with the kind of
crime thriller zodiac vibes he's
bringing there could be some potential
for more deranged psychological horror i
mean it's always in the flavors of a
batman movie but i feel like especially
if you're getting a guy like barry hogan
who can walk around in those tones as a
performer and then also transcribe them
into the visual dna of the film and
everything like i think this could be
the most horror-centric batman thus far
perhaps i mean at least that would be my
hope too because i mean barry cogan like
you know he's he's done an array of of
kinds of films but it's clear that he
can thrive in that more genre and more
you know again horror-centric
environment and so yeah to see him like
really transcending and you know build
his caliber as an actor it seems like
kind of a perfect time in his career to
jump into such a high profile take on a
beloved character like this it's gonna
be interesting to see how audiences
respond to that because too he's not
like the biggest household name because
i feel like heath ledger was already
like a heartthrob by the time they
brought him in jared leto is you know
he's got a stature from his bands and
from you know his acting work joaquin
phoenix is this elder statesman actor by
this point whereas barry kilgan is still
on the come up but he's very much
arrived and maybe this could be the
opportunity to also take the gloves off
and now perform on that scale with that
level of spectacle but also with a bit
more you know the personal and the
intimate acting involved whereas in this
world given such a juicy role i can't
wait to see just how much he gets to do
with all that and really gets to take
the gloves off you know and of course
too if you're an actor who's playing
he's his marvel superhero and then he
would be like one of the biggest dc
villains that's just nuts to me
everything is at your disposal i mean if
he's going from maternals to a batman
movie at that point you could just
choose any role but anyway guys what do
you think about the thought of barry
kogan playing the joker does it excite
you is it cool do you love it do you not
like it
you sick of the joker leave your
thoughts down below subscribe click that
bell hit that like button we'll catch
you guys soon